bashir rahama is still searching for
what he can salvage from his home it
collapsed on tuesday after flash floods
in mikaela in northern sudan's river now
state it's the result of days of heavy
rains in the region and rain water from
the east overflowing streams in the town
the rain started in the morning it
stopped raining for hours and then while
we were opening the streams for water to
pass the floods hit us it didn't stop
till the next morning the rain waters
usually just flow through the stream but
this time we went over it and no barrier
or stream was able to stop it
bashir's home was one of more than
seventeen hundred homes destroyed by the
floods in mikhail uptown alone more than
three thousand homes were damaged in
berber county and what many here say has
been the worst destruction they've seen
mahmoud abdullah shows us what remains
of his once large family home where
rooms once stood now only rubble remains
there were two bedrooms there another
two on the other side and a kitchen
there
the water came and in less than an hour
the houses collapsed we didn't even have
a chance to take out anything because we
were busy making sure that people got
out alive
some have left their homes to seek
shelter after losing nearly everything
but many others have stayed behind
the destruction has left families out in
the open many say they'll wait here
until the end of the rainy season to
rebuild their homes but that may take
some time because more rain is forecast
in the coming days and there are
concerns about waterborne diseases
the rain and flood waters have damaged
sewage systems and it's hard to find
drinking water in some parts of the town
my life
there is no access to clean drinking
water or to a health clinic my daughter
is now sick in a tent nearby while we'll
try to salvage what we can but there is
no medical treatment available
at least 15 people have been killed as a
result of heavy rains and flash floods
around sudan those who survived say
they're not sure how they'll be able to
rebuild their lives after losing so much
well that was hibern reporting from
berber and just a short while ago she
sent us this update
the start of the rainy season in some
parts of the country it's already made
rainy season in other parts of the
country but the devastation is now
growing wider and wider to include more
counties around the country and here in
berber
where people have lost most of their
positions they're still waiting for
assistance people have been living out
in the open they're trying to cope with
what has happened
on tuesday some of them saying that
they're still trying to take out the
positions that they can
salvage from the ruins trying to find
higher places away from the flood waters
because they're expecting more rains in
the coming days now they say that they
have not seen this kind of destruction
before therefore
they're not sure how to cope with the
situation they've lost
the local market where they used to buy
uh their vegetables and their food they
still don't have access to clean water
and they're still lacking access to
health care and medication so they're
saying that it's very hard to deal with
the current situation in light of the
fact that this is the first time it's
happening for to them well the
government government has created an
emergency room for uh the state as well
as for other states around the country
to deal with the issues of flooding
flash flooding and the displacement of
people and losing their properties but
the issue is especially here in mikaela
in berber county people say they've been
waiting for three days for tents because
they're now out in the open and that has
not been distributed out to them they
say that they're expecting more rains in
the coming days so they don't know how
they'll be able to deal with that
situation many of them still out in the
open many of them still waiting to be
able to get food they say that they're
sharing uh with their neighbors what
they can both food and clean water but
they say they're yet to see any form of
assistance from both the government and
aid organizations